les travailleurs étrangers qui reçoivent
une fraction du salaire de leurs
collègues québécois des visas trop
restrictifs qui les exposent aux abus
des accidents de travail en forteresse
ce sont des problèmes qui sont revenus à
l'avant-plan de l'actualité de la
semaine dernière et qui force Québec
imposer des mesures de surveillance plus
musclées le gouvernement promet
d'ajouter des inspecteurs de mieux
informer les salariés étrangers de leur
garantie quand ils viennent ici qu'ils
auront les mêmes droits que leurs
collègues du Québec mais à quel point le
problème est-il criant j'en discute avec
le ministre du Travail jean-boulli que
je retrouve dans nos studios
Trois-Rivières merci d'être avec nous
monsieur le ministre bonjour monsieur
Thibault quand vous avez entendu les
histoires chez BRP la semaine dernière
parce que c'est ça qui a relancé toute
l'affaire comment vous avez réagi
qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé
de Monsieur EDN Radio-Canada était bien
fouillée bien documenté ceci dit à ce
stand 6 ça demeure des allégations si ça
s'avère fonder bien sûr c'est
inadmissible inacceptable les
travailleurs étrangers en parent on en a
besoin au Québec pour répondre à nos à
la pénurie de main d'oeuvre la majorité
des employeurs les accueille avec équité
dans un environnement de travail qui est
sain et sécuritaire et le cas de BRP
bien sûr on a délégué à la cnsst
désinspecteurs qui recueillent
l'information qui vont analyser les
documents obtenus et ici ça s'avère réel
on va prendre les mesures qui s'imposent
avec les constats d'infraction puis les
conséquences pour l'accompagner
concernée
ça veut dire quoi les conséquences ça
veut dire qu'on va compenser ces
travailleurs-là on va les remettre la
compagnie à la main comment ça
fonctionne c'est sûr que on va émettre
des avis de correction ça pourra aller à
des constats transaction et le paiement
d'amende si le tribunal en vient à la
conclusion qui a effectivement eu
contravention à nos lois sur les normes
du travail parce que c'est important de
le répéter les travailleurs étrangers
ont droit au même bénéfice que les
travailleurs québécois en matière de
Nord d'équité salariale et de santé
sécurité du travail donc il y aurait des
amendes par individu par infraction à la
Loi sur les normes du travail et les
conséquences réputationnelles encore une
fois si ça s'avère fondé bon vous avez
vous avez dit tout à l'heure c'est c'est
l'école d'exception la plupart des
employeurs traitent bien ces
travailleurs-là n'empêche savez-vous
l'impression que il y a des employeurs
qui en profitent un peu parce que ils
viennent pas d'ici ce monde-là qui
connaissent pas notre système puis qui
essaie de le remplacer une petite vitre
il faut lutter contre ce phénomène là je
ne le ni pas probablement que les
employeurs qui profitent de ce système
là qui nous permet d'accéder à des
travailleurs étrangers temporaires mais
c'est la raison pour laquelle cette
semaine j'ai annoncé un renforcement de
notre escouade prévention maintenant ça
va s'appliquer dans tous les secteurs
d'activité économiques c'est plus que
dans le domaine agricole on va faire une
vérification systématique des agences de
recrutement de travailleur étrangers
temporaires qui ont des obligations on
va éviter que ces cas-là surviennent au
Québec on pourra pas complètement les
éliminer mais on s'est donné une
structure d'intervention avec près de
500 inspecteurs en matière d'un arbre
santé sécurité équité pour faire de la
prévention de la sensibilisation de
l'information et des enquêtes qui seront
de nature à vérifier si nos lois sont
bien respectées par les employeurs
monsieur voulait ces enquêteurs en
général elles sont faites après avoir
avisé l'employeur que l'inspecteur s'en
vient est-ce que ça c'est pas une
la cnsst peut intervenir sans préavis
par exemple si on a des informations qui
nous permettent de croire que il y a eu
des violations de nos lois ils peuvent
intervenir sans préavis et sachez que en
vertu d'un règlement qu'on a adopté le
premier janvier 2020 les agences de
recrutement doivent obtenir un permis et
les employeurs doivent informer la cnsst
dès qu'ils embauchent des travailleurs
étrangers temporaires donc on est en
mesure de cibler les employeurs par
secteur d'activité économiques et comme
vous savez on est pensé d'à peu près
23000 à
38500 de 2019 à 2022 donc il y en a
beaucoup plus qui sont disséminés dans
les entreprises et les différents
secteurs d'activités et on fait des
interventions sans prévenir d'avance
nécessairement deux derniers éléments
monsieur boulet on dénonce le fait
plusieurs dénonces le fait que le visa
restreint le travailleur à un seul
employeur et que ça l'expose à des abus
potentiels est-ce que la solution ce
serait pas de laisser des visas ouverts
pour ce genre là bon évidemment
la mettons-nous de la perspective d'un
employeur qui investit dans une étude
d'impact sur le marché du travail c'est
des coûts c'est des honorins la
procédure est longue les délaisses sont
quand même assez importants on investit
pour avoir quelqu'un on souhaite avoir
un permis de travail fermé ceci dit de
la perspective du travailleur bien sûr
quand il est victime d'abus ou de
discrimination il y a des possibilités
de transformer son permis fermé en
permis ouvert en faisant une
dénonciation à développement social
Canada et évidemment vous savez que ce
programme là des travailleurs étrangers
temporaires relèvent d'Ottawa mais il
est géré conjointement par Québec et
Ottawa mais il y a des possibilités mais
il dénonce pas ces gens là parce qu'ils
ont peur des représailles comment vous
faites pour les convaincre c'est correct
de dénoncer
c'est correct c'est la raison pour
laquelle on fait des ateliers de
sensibilisation puis d'informations les
personnes qui arrivent ici que ce soit
en français en anglais ou en espagnol on
les informe le plus adéquatement
possible de leur droit de leur bénéfices
et de la possibilité de dénoncer s'ils
font l'objet d'une mise à pied ou d'un
congédiment illégal ou d'un abus ou
d'une discrimination ils peuvent
s'assurer d'être aidé on va les
accompagner puis développement social
Canada vont respecter ces mesures ces
programmes et transformer le permis
fermé en permis ouvert mais est-ce qu'on
devra avoir un accès plus généralisé au
permis de travail ouvert peut-être dans
certains cas mais je pense que ça mérite
une analyse approfondie j'en voulais
ministre du Travail du Québec merci
d'avoir été des nôtres
merci Monsieur Thibault au plaisir